[Music]
there really aren't any secrets in the
pros
you know either um
like i said there really aren't any
secrets you know i saw like an interview
yesterday i think it was mike florio and
chris samson was like man this i don't
want to go tell them my tricks i'm uh i
mean it's not it's not really like that
it's really not like a
a secret move that i got in my bag that
i can that i'm holding from everybody
else you know that because you can see i
mean you see everything i got on film
you know it's just a place where we can
all compare you know what we're doing
super bowl 50 mvp von miller speaking to
reporters on tuesday vaughn thank you
thank you what up vaughn
thank you thank you for watching the
show vaughn we appreciate that we love
von miller he's one of our favorite
guests he is and and and i want to make
sure because i think he is focusing
chris on one very specific point you
made almost kind of in jest that when
khalil mack sacks joe flacco
and and the bears will play the broncos
this year
khalil mack is using von miller's spin
move
that's not our point our point is the
act of drawing everyone together all
these pass rushers and comparing notes
on all the things they learn all the
things they've heard that makes them
better this isn't about secret moves
this is about pulling information
gathering your your experiences and
helping each other get better that's the
problem because you're helping guys get
better who play for other teams who are
eventually going to be trying to put joe
flacco on his ass yes yeah exactly i
mean first off this von miller's a great
guy it's really cool that he does this
thing i want to make sure that's known
okay i really do it is cool would i have
done it no but there's certain there's
certain you know things to admire about
it so i'm not sitting here trying to bag
on von miller and i understand what von
saying yeah well he he's right he's not
holding any tricks or you know holding
any moves back and going oh i'm going to
unveil this in week 12. nobody's seen
this one yet i get that my point and you
know obviously i didn't you know uh make
it clear enough would be yes everybody
knows what you do von miller those
things but there might be certain
technique aspects that you might have
had one coach who you know explained a
certain technique to you on your spin
move that made you that much better at
your spin move that now you might share
with somebody else i hope i'm being
clear there but let me just put it this
way like
hey i had offensive coordinators we
might have had the same two plays right
what bad offensive coordinator would
teach the play this way you know good
offensive coordinator here's the same
play he would give me a little different
coaching point that i never thought of
with the play and all of a sudden i said
holy cow this play makes so much more
sense
i'm so much better at it now i
understand that i see it more just
because he made that one little point
about oh just read this instead of that
which the bad coach was telling me to do
and now it totally changes your outlook
or your play or whatever it may be or
even with a quarterback mechanic you
know hey the coach has been telling me
to do this and that good coach is just
going hey nice throw you know i mean bad
coach is going hey you know nice throw
good coach is going hey if you put your
foot just a little bit different on your
release you know it might add some power
to your game or your throws or whatever
it may be and you go oh okay that makes
sense so that's what i was talking about
just little nuances that might you know
spark a light in a guy's brain to go oh
that's his that's his technique teaching
point that makes him so good at that i
get it and now i can get it and become
better at it too chris if everybody
shows up at that pass rush summit with
the one most important thing they've
learned at any point during their nfl
career or college career about how to
rush the passer and they all share it
yeah and they all say wow
and they say wow 20 different times they
all come out of it better than they are
when they went in as to the tricks of
the trade of getting to quarterbacks
consider this caleas campbell jaguar's
defensive lineman
he said yesterday i picked demarcus
ware's brain for a solid hour straight
just talking ball and seeing that level
of understanding and he went back and
immediately started teaching other
jaguars players on the things he learned
right every little bit counts campbell
said if we can just get a little better
each and every day we've got so much
potential and guess what jaguars broncos
week four
circle that game let's see how many
times kalea's campbell and company get
to joe flacco and in the aftermath of
that game i can't wait to hear caleas
campbell say man i used all that stuff i
learned at the vaughn miller pass rush
summit to sac von miller's quarterback
six times yeah no i mean that's a it's a
very real possibility it really is and
you know this is what this is why
there's good coaches and bad coaches you
know there's just there's i was around
hall of fame players who came to a team
and all of a sudden got around a really
good coach at their position they went
whoa my gosh he taught me a few things i
didn't know i became even better
football player so just because you all
know the same moves doesn't know
necessarily you have the techniques to
execute them the right way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports